bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaires pour parlement
hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité politique
et parlementaire avec céline bittner
bonjour céline mongin michael est dans
l'actualité cette semaine le traité
budgétaires européens examinés et votés
par l'assemblée et le sénat
pas ou peu de suspense si ce n'est le
nombre de votes contre dans les rangs du
parti socialiste au total vingt députés
et trois sénateurs n'ont pas voté en
faveur de ce texte la polémique de la
semaine on la doit à jean françois copé
en pleine campagne pour la présidence de
l'ump l affaire dite du pain au chocolat
secoue la droite entre tenant d'une
ligne force et décomplexé celle du large
rassemblement que prône françois fillon
les deux camps s'affrontent
enfin nous parlerons de cette future loi
qui crée aussi des remous à droite le
mariage pour tous fronde des maires ump
qui ne veulent pas célébrer ces mariages
et évoque un droit de conscience a droit
de retrait et préfèrent déléguer à leurs
adjoints réactions à droite comme à
gauche
à suivre dans notre émission est avec
nous pour commenter l'actualité de la
semaine nicolas dupont aignan bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député de l'essonne
président de debout la république
vous êtes l'autre nicolas de l'élection
présidentielle mais pas de second tour
pour vous mais une septième place dans
cette course à l'elysée alors vous avez
obtenu 1,6 pour cent des suffrages c'est
moins bien que les verts mais c'est
mieux que philippe poutou
il paraît qu'on ne doit pas vous
qualifiez de souverainistes vous trouvez
ça réducteur mais plutôt de gaulliste
social en tout cas votre cheval de
bataille c'est la sortie de l'euro et le
patriotisme tranquille c'est vous qui le
dites
et pour compléter ce portrait regarder
ce que pensent les députés vos collègues
à l'assemblée nationale regardez ce
qu'ils pensent de vous il a la qualité
de la puye a cité il s'accroche à ses
idées il essaie de les faire partager
c'est déjà à saluer
intelligent et les travailleurs il a une
relation à sa circonscription qui est
tout à fait exceptionnel les réélu dans
des conditions extrêmement brillante
j'apprécie la force de ses convictions
et son courage et j'ai pour lui le
l'estimé et l'amitié qu'on les
combattants pour les autres combattants
et il suit sa ligne
je pense que c'est effectivement une
qualité un défaut eh ben c'est de
combattre sol comme nous le faisons sa
volonté d'avoir raison contre tous les
autres ou d'être celui qui veut prêcher
dans une forme de d2 isolement politique
qui n'est jamais bonne crois que c'est
quelqu'un qui est sincère encore une
fois qui est peut-être un peu imbu de
lui-même
pourquoi en 10 mm parce qu'ils pensent
avoir la vérité en politique il faut
toujours affronter les avis des autres
alors défaut il n'aurait pas dû partir
de l'ump alors nicolas dupont aignan
c'est un homme seul trop seul mais je
n'ai pas le sentiment de me sentir seul
je vais vous dire vous surprendre
d'abord j'ai eu quand même sept cent
mille voix présidentielle on m'avait dit
que j'aurais 0 5% aussi les sondages
négatifs avait existé on m'aurait dit
moins bon ensuite y'a phénomène avant et
mais depuis la présidentielle très vrai
c'est qu'on a beaucoup de ralliement de
français de gens très différentes qui
souvent n'ont jamais eu d'engagement
politique et qu'ils ont compris eux ce
que je proposais c'est-à-dire ce
patriotisme républicain
ce qui manque terriblement à mon avis à
la vie politique
et quand je vois le nombre de personnes
qui nous rejoignent en ce moment de tous
horizons de tous métiers de toutes
origines
je me dis qu'on est en train de bâtir
quelque chose de neuf nous avons entendu
ces députés ils disent ils n'auraient
pas dû partir de l'ump ben moi je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire parce que je
crois justement les français n'en
peuvent plus des contorsionnistes ce que
j'appelle les contorsionnistes ce sont
des gens qui défendent une idée en
public et qui appartiennent à des
groupes politiques qui font exactement
l'un vers ce qu'ils votent linverse et
je crois que si un tel désaveu de la
chose publique dans notre pays c'est
parce que les français n'en peuvent plus
de ces hommes politiques qui ne sont pas
cohérents on va passer vous connaissez
le principe de notre émission va
dérouler toute l'actualité de la semaine
et on commence évidemment par le lundi
la police démantèle un réseau islamiste
un vaste coup de filet dans les réseaux
de l'islamisme radical une cellule
terroriste démantelée par les services
de renseignement et de la police des
plus dangereux depuis 1996 dit même le
procureur de la police et le procureur
de paris ce qui fera bien sûr ce sont
leurs profils de plus en plus jeunes et
souvent passés par la prison les
explications de jérôme rabin depuis la
ferme mohamed merah c'est la hantise des
services de renseignement français
des jeunes bien intégré né en france et
qui basculent dans la radicalité des
profils difficiles à détecter
ces investigations ont permis de mettre
à jour un réseau
je dirais quasiment une cellule toutes
ces personnes nées en france est de
nationalité française sont en lien avec
la mouvance radicale islamiste
une cellule démantelée à la suite de
l'interpellation à strasbourg cannes et
en banlieue parisienne interpellations
au cours desquelles le leader présumé
jérémy louis sydney a été tué une arme à
la main on le voit ici dans une vidéo
postée sur internet c'était le plus âgé
il avait 33 ans
les autres membres sont tous des jeunes
âgés de 18 à 25 ans la plupart
converties sur le tard à l'islam on à
faire y compris là des jeunes convertis
qui vivaient dans certaines conditions
fragments défragmentation du lien social
dislocation des liens familiaux perte de
repères les nouveaux convertis sont
généralement plus facilement quels que
soient les confessions des religions
plus facilement radicaux radicalisation
qui s'est opéré sur des forums sur le
net dans des lieux de prières auprès d'
imam intégriste ou en prison
un terrorisme à la française née en
france souvent en banlieue alimenter
puis entretenu par un antisémitisme
primaire mais aussi par le rejet de
l'occident alors nicolas dupont aignan
on l'a vu dans ce sujet ce qui change
bien sûr c'est aussi se profile sont de
plus en plus jeunes mais souvent passés
par la prison et radicalisé par la
prison est ce que nos prisons sont
malades aujourd'hui
d'abord je voudrais saluer les forces de
l'ordre parce qu'il est bon souvent de
les critiquer il y en a beaucoup qui
critique mais moi je voudrais dire que
quand on donne des moyens à la police
on s'aperçoit que la police est efficace
il faut saluer ces femmes et ces hommes
qui ont pris le risque de se faire tuer
on oublie trop souvent ensuite sur la
prison mais c'est parce que la prison
n'est pas tenue en france
je voyais hier des syndicalistes de
prison qui me racontait des choses
ahurissantes
ils font des signalements mais en prison
comme ailleurs dans notre pays c'est
surtout pas de vagues où on a laissé
tomber les gardiens de prison on a
réduit les effectifs on n'a pas
construit à cette prison ce qui fait que
les prisons ne sont pas bien gérés
mais bien évidemment et les moyens
peuvent changer simplement a coûté le
félin gardien avait quelqu'un au prix
souhaité quant à gardiens de prison me
disait hier qu'il y à un détenu pour
cent prisonniers et qu'on leur demande
de repérer des radicaux quand ils
signalent des radicaux islamistes en
prison et quand certains islamistes
radicaux en prison ne veulent pas parler
ils ne veulent pas de garder par une
femme est gla hiérarchie policière cède
et la hiérarchie pardon pénitentiaire ça
veut dire qu'il ya un vrai problème de
laisser-aller de l'état et de la
république
et si on avait été plus ferme dans notre
pays on n'aurait pas ces phénomènes si
on avait par exemple
arrêtez vous vous êtes vous même vous
êtes maire devant lui est ce que vous
observez des jeunes musulmans nés en
france qui se radicalise de plus en plus
j'ai observé des volontés de certains
extrémistes s'emparent et d'associations
notamment musulmanes et c'est là où nous
devons conforter les français qui
pratiquent la religion musulmane de
manière tolérante nous devons les
conforter l'état doit la conforter et en
revanche l'état doit expulser beaucoup
plus fréquemment les imams qui prêchent
les discours de haine
je demande une mesure simple simple que
le français soit la langue des prêches
dans tous les
toutes les religions d'ailleurs et
notamment dans les mosquées
je demande qu'on arrête le financement
étranger des mosquées je demande qu'on
forme en france par une formation
organisée par l'état les imams tant
qu'on ne n'organisera pas l'islam de
france est con
coprah pas le lien avec des puissances
étrangères on n'y arrivera pas et ça ça
veut dire un changement radical de
vision des choses elle est en avance
lundi a toujours jamais un pain au
chocolat n'aura autant fait parler jean
françois copé a créé une nouvelle
polémique après celle sur le racisme
anti blanc le prétendant à la tête de
l'ump a évoqué l'arrachage de pain au
chocolat part je cite des voyous sous
prétexte de ramadan il s'est attiré une
volée de critiques entre ironie et
indignation marion lefebvre
pas de doute la bataille de l'ump c'est
bel et bien déplacé sur le terrain
idéologique une nouvelle fois les propos
de jean françois copé suscite la
polémique
il est des quartiers où je peux
comprendre l'exaspération certains de
nos compatriotes pères ou mères de
famille rentrant du travail le soir
apprenant que leur fils s'est fait
arracher son pain au chocolat à la
sortie du collège par des voyous il lui
explique qu on mange pas content le
ramadan c'était vendredi lors d'un
meeting à draguignan dans le var et jean
françois copé place la barre très à
droite
elle assume une droite dit-il
décomplexée et vives critiques à gauche
mais aussi à droite le camps fillon
prend ouvertement ses distances
il est en train de se passer ce que
pardon je redoutais c'est à dire que la
logique des campagnes électorales fait
quand on cherche à se distinguer de son
partenaire homme seul adversaire est
qu'on ait conduit à durcir le ton et ça
je crois que ça ne va pas dans la bonne
direction pour françois baroin c'est
même une erreur d' analyse des petites
phrases toxiques et dangereuse rappelant
que l'ump refuse tous les extrémismes
fallait-il s'engager sur ce terrain là
dans la campagne pour la direction de
l'ump eric ciotti s'interroge est-ce
qu'il faut parler que de ça durant une
campagne pour la présidence de l'ump qui
a vocation à choisir le chef de
l'opposition et donc à conduire
l'alternance pour notre pays c'est une
autre question chacun son outil non moi
je préfère aux paroles fortes les actes
forts et discours qui rassemble ou
discours minoritaire elle les militants
ump trancheront le 18 novembre prochain
lorsqu ils désigneront le futur
président de l'ue m
le racisme anti-blanc ses propos sur les
pains au chocolat ces sondes et n 2 du
front national est ce que jean françois
copé selon voies à raison de reprendre
ces thèmes-là de droitiser son discours
ce qui m'agace et qu'on va parler que de
ça mais parlons du fond des choses jean
françois copé a raison de décrire ce qui
se passe dans nos banlieues et
j'entendais votre reportage en disant
très à droite mais c'est pas une
question de droite et de gauche
moi j'ai des gens de gauche qui sont
horrifiés de ce qui se passe de cette
pression de certains s'extrait mist de
certains extrémistes musulmans qui
déconsidère la religion musulmane dans
notre pays et le dire tout de suite
c'est le drame
mais il mais il existe mais écoutez
c'est pas une question de front national
c'est la question de la réalité de ce
qui se passe dans notre pays parce que
la république a été faible on peut être
de gauche du sang de droite d'extrême
droite pour constater des choses
en revanche où je suis un peu en
désaccord avec jean françois copé c'est
qu'il ya quand même gouverné pendant dix
ans et que c'est le bilan d'une
faiblesse de l'état et de la république
depuis 20 ans gauche droite confondues
et que la question n'est pas tant de
décrire ce qui se passe que de trouver
les moyens pour réconcilier les français
c'est à dire quelle que soit la couleur
de sa peau son origine et sa religion
ceux qui respectent la république doit
faire partir d'un beau projet national
et c'est là où je diverge de jean
françois copé comme d autres parce qu'en
vérité copé fillon c'est la même chose
ils n'ont qu'un projet national mais
colette dupouy on n'aurait pas un grand
projet national pour la france
vous ne pourrez pas réconcilier les
français et vous sombrerait dans des
polémiques là juste pour revenir sur
cela copé fillon c'est pareil
vous avez plutôt l'impression qu'il ya
un discours décomplexé comme le dit jean
françois copé est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ses disques au gym à jean
que vous n'êtes pas vraiment fillon mais
plutôt copé dans ces cas là pendant cinq
ans sous sarkozy a eu un discours avec
des choses vraies mais n'a jamais eu les
actes concordants il a supprimé des
places de prison aux actes et aux raids
à supprimer des places de policiers par
dont il a voulu augmenter les places de
prison mais ça c'est pas fait vraiment
supprimer des places de gendarmes des
postes de gendarmes
il n'y a jamais eu de suite la loi dati
est une loi de laxisme judiciaire
ahurissante
donc moi je m'en fous du discours
pardonnez moi d'être peu vulgaire je
veux qu'en fait ça oui parce que je suis
élu de banlieue
j'ai vu l'état affaibli je veux une
république debout c'est le type de
mouvement mais je veux une république
qui à la fois rassemblé français mais
qui soit capable de prendre des
décisions au copé fillon héros hollande
font partie de cette caste politique qui
depuis 20 ans ont abîmé la république
ont signé notamment des accords
européens qu'on supprime les frontières
qui a fait la double peine a supprimé la
double peine c'est à dire en france
avant on pouvait expulser les étrangers
délinquants qui a supprimé c'est sarko
show mais juste sur le disque politique
de l'ump court derrière des phénomènes
en fait tous
ils ont un discours politique qui
s'explique par des sondages par du
ressenti par de la sincérité eux
et puis il ya la pratique est une
pratique d'abandon moi je veux -
discours et plus d'actes et le tout dans
un dans la sérénité
et là vous verrez que vous arriverez à
réconcilier les français quelle que soit
leur couleur et leur origine et leur
religion mais en étant ferme
allez on passe à mardi et le
gouvernement pousse un ouf de
soulagement il peut tourner la page du
traité européen
les voix de la gauche ont finalement
suffi à faire adopter le pacte
budgétaire européen le gouvernement n'a
pas eu besoin de la droite même si les
socialistes n'ont pas fait le carton
plein malgré les pressions 20 députés ps
n'ont pas cédé aux sirènes de leur parti
et ont voté contre
les explications dame et à vire pour 477
contre 70 l'assemblée nationale adoptait
adopter le traité budgétaire européen
c'est la fin d'un vrai faux suspense
plus qu'une grande partie de la gauche
majoritaire une grande partie de
l'opposition avait indiqué qu'elle
allait voter pour toute la question
était de savoir avec quelle voie le
traité serait adoptée et si l'apport de
la droite serait décisif
la réponse est donnée par le premier
ministre en personne à l'assemblée
nationale s'est passé le premier
ministre une conférence de presse
annoncée à la dernière minute et un chef
du gouvernement plutôt satisfait ce qui
s'est passé aussi et qui est très
important pour le gouvernement c'est
qu'une majorité de gauche à l'assemblée
nationale s'est prononcé favorablement
au parti socialiste 20 députés ont voté
contre le traité gratifié ils rentrent
dans le rang
ma position était quand même assez
claire de ménibus à l'ump même si on a
appelé à voter pour le traité c'est
quand même nicolas sarkozy qui l'a
négocié on ironise sur la méthode du
gouvernement
christian jacob en est convaincu jean
marc ayrault vrai mis un pistolet sur la
tempe des députés ps pour qu'ils votent
le texte
le premier ministre est à ce point
faibli qu'il en est obligé d'appeler
individuellement parlementaires prg et
parlementaires bon ça laisse mal augurer
pour eux des semaines qui viennent
le texte prévoit la réduction drastique
et contraintes du déficit public avec
l'instauration d'une règle d'or le
déficit public structurel ne doit pas
dépasser les 0 points 5 % de la richesse
du pays
autres interdictions la dette du pays
doit être inférieur à 60% du produit
intérieur brut la fin de la souveraineté
du parlement en matière budgétaire pour
les députés du front de gauche
écologistes ou souverainistes qui ont
voté contre
pour rassurer les partisans du non
le gouvernement le répète en boucle le
traité budgétaire n'est qu'une étape
ce qui compte ce sont les prochaines là
vous prédisiez un qu'avec l'adoption du
traité budgétaire hors pair la france
perde sa souveraineté sa souveraineté
son indépendance budgétaire et donc que
l'assemblée nationale devient la muse
est depuis mardi vous êtes quoi un
conservateur anarchie vite médard pense
que les députés ont applaudi leur
suicide politique
et ce faisant c'est beaucoup plus grave
ce qui s'est produit c'est les français
qui perdent le pouvoir budgétaire et le
pouvoir fiscal et ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que dans quelques mois nous
aurons des commissaires non élus de
bruxelles qui viendront dicter leur loi
au peuple français
parce que ce qui est tragique dans cette
affaire c'est que dans l'indifférence
générale
nos collègues ont voté un texte qui
n'ont pas lu dans l'indifférence
générale
ils ont abandonné le pouvoir qui est à
l'origine de la naissance du parlement
et ce faisant ils n'auront même pas de
bons résultats mais moi je vais vous
lire une phrase j'ai après je vous posez
une colle dans le canard enchaîné d'hier
ce traité est une illusion mais c'est
aussi un risque celui de devoir faire
dans quelques mois ou dans quelques
années après des affres des efforts
parfois insupportable pour les européens
le constat de l'échec et de
l'impuissance à votre jeu françois
hollande dans son discours prononcé à
paris le 17 mars à chaussures lors
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire mes
regrets totalement raison ce traité ce
traité la part de françois lenglet et ça
mais c'est pire qu'un renoncement 6 la
bonne gestion
soyons clair moi j'ai désendetter ma
ville de moitié en 15 ans donc la bonne
gestion je connais la bonne gestion il
la faut mais là c'est pas de la bonne
gestion on fait croire qu'on va bien
gérer le pays parce qu'on va confier le
pouvoir à des gens non élus
mais ces gens non élus de bruxelles
depuis 20 ans mène une politique
suicidaire pour l'europe et sont en
train d'appuyer sur le frein dans tous
les pays au point de créer une récession
qui va aboutir à avoir encore plus de
déficit et de dette à la fin de l'année
donc non seulement on abandonne notre
pouvoir mais on le donne à des gens
incompétents qui vont créer le chaos
économique et social et bien moi je vous
dis je suis fier d'avoir voté contre
avec 70 dont une vingtaine plus de 20 à
droite notamment à l'ump
ce qui veut dire quelque chose change
parce que les gens ont de la raison y
réfléchisse si je vous dit le prix nobel
de la paix a été attribué à l'union
européenne ue surpoids ou pas oui parce
que c'est une plaisanterie à l'idée
européenne pourquoi pas parce que l'idée
européenne qu'on soit clair entre nous
parce qu'on ne présente toujours le
anti-européen pas du tout l'europe c'est
l'idéal de réconciliation après la
seconde guerre mondiale et c'est une
idée magnifique magnifique mais cette
europe là elle est totalement trahie par
le pouvoir qu'on a donné à des
irresponsables qui sont en train de
créer
la réplique de la crise de 29 en europe
qui je vous le rappelle en allemagne a
amené hitler année la guerre donc
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez ce qui
se passe en grèce en espagne
quand vous voyez les conflits qui a qui
monte entre les pays d'europe
donner le prix nobel de la paix l'union
européenne c'est un contresens total
parce que aujourd'hui la politique de
l'union européenne qui crée la misère en
europe est en train de nous préparer des
lendemains très dur et donc moi je
demande une autre europe
c'est à dire qu'on change radicalement
le fonctionnement de l'europe et pour ça
faut pas avoir des députés
on va dire que je suis des députés comme
des moutons qui vont voter un texte
suicidaire mais c'est absurde ce qu'ils
ont fait alors les députés ont voté vous
savez qu'au sénat aussi l'examen
j'espère qu'ils réaliseront un peu plus
j'ai écouté ses quelques sénateurs à la
tribune c'était lors du vote sur le
traité écouter
ne comptez pas sur nous cette
ratification monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre est à nos
yeux une faute politique
oui une faute vous avez été élu pour
conduire le changement
non pas pour emprunter les pas du
sarkozysme le gouvernement considère que
c'est un mal nécessaire de ratifier
maintenant ce traité nous nous
considérons que c'est amal qui n'est pas
nécessaire qui est même très encombrant
et qui va extrêmement compliqué la tâche
dans les mois à venir pour l'action
gouvernementale vous ne serez pas
surpris monsieur le ministre que le vote
auquel j'appelle soit non pas bien
entendu un vote de confiance parce que
de ce côté ci nous ne partageons pas le
chemin
mais un vote de continuité car il faut
assumer la continuité de l'état
ah vous voyez il ya des pouilles à des
contres et pas forcément sur les bons
auquel on s'attendait entendu jean va
surpasser pour les verts mais sur le
fond cette fois il n'y aura pas de règle
d'or dans la constitution c'est aussi ce
que vous réclamiez donc plus de
souveraineté
est ce que c'est la loi organique mais
le problème que cette langue a dit
qu'elle a été votée avec un petit peu
plus de voix prévu je lisais ce matin
dans un grand journal
madame lagarde va dire qu'on est
d'accord gens savent du fmi qui disait
que ces objectifs n'ont aucun sens
le continent européen est en train de
s'enfoncer dans la crise
e nous avons le record de faillites nous
aurons d'après les économistes sérieux 1
qui sont pas pour moi
six cent mille chômeurs de plus dans un
an le déficit de la france dans un an ne
sera pas 3% il sera de 4 ou 5 % nous
sommes en train d'aller dans une déroute
économique et tout le monde dit il faut
il faut mais il faut changer de
politique et notamment
il faut comprendre que la dette et
j'insiste là dessus pour ceux qui nous
écoutent la dette les déficits ils sont
pas liées à l'excès de dépenses et
retient des dépenses à réduire bien sûr
mais ils sont liés surtout à
l'effondrement des recettes liées aux
délocalisations
donc tant que vous ne traiterait pas la
fuite des emplois à l'étranger
un million d'emplois industriels perdus
en disant 500 milles devant nous qui
vont partir des pertes de savoir faire
tant que vous noterez
rep à la cause des délocalisations vous
ne traiterait pas la cause des déficits
et voilà pourquoi je propose des choses
concrètes je les fais pendant la
présidentielle diminution de moitié de
l'impôt sur les sociétés pour les
investissements en france ça c'est
concret sortie de l'euro barrières
douanières quand on respecte pas les
normes européennes
puis il y avait regardé j'ai un
gouvernement vous estimez que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui n'applique pas
les bonnes recettes mais ça voulait dire
évidemment le gouvernement réoriente mur
toutes les dépenses dont les dépenses
d'investissement ce qui est suicidaire
il faut mieux gérer et voilà on sait ça
ils vont relancer l'économie faut bien
gérer et réduire les dépenses excessives
y en a 10 milliards qu'on donne par
exemple à l'union européenne en pure
perte des déficits là il bosse bien j'ai
même gagné on est d'accord il y en a il
faut les réduire
mais il faut parallèlement crée de la
compétitivité baisser les charges des
entreprises créent de la richesse dans
notre pays et inciter les entreprises à
relocaliser leurs investissements et
pour ça il faut sortir de cette monnaie
qui nous enfoncent qu'est l'euro il faut
contrôler les produits qui arrivent au
havre est ce que vous savez un exemple
très concret que 20% des produits qui a
dans les containers qui viennent de
chine ne respectent pas les normes
européennes
c'est elle qu'on pourrait les refoulés
mais on fait rien eu il faut baisser les
charges des pme ça veut dire qu'il faut
d'un côté bien gérer nos dépenses bien
sûr mais il faut créer de la
compétitivité de l'emploi en france
sinon on finira comme la grèce et comme
l'espagne j'insiste j'insiste parce que
on ne vous vraiment les dirigeants
d'aujourd'hui sont totalement
incompétents qu'ils soient ump/ps ratu
accrochage alors le non cumul des
mandats voilà un débat en tout cas qui
enflamme députés et sénateurs la
commission présidée par lionel jospin
poursuit son travail autour de la
rénovation la vie publique l'ancien
premier ministre a un tout petit peu
lever le voile sur ce dossier même s'ils
ne faut pas pour l'heure en tirer aucune
conclusion le point d'étape avec marie
et brémaud lionel jospin a voulu garder
une part de mystère sur les propositions
finales de la commission de rénovation
et de d
anthologie mais une chose semble
aujourd'hui certaines l'étau se resserre
autour des parlementaires la commission
préconise une limitation étroite du
cumul des mandats
nous n'envisageons pas a priori d'opérer
des distinctions entre les députés et
les sénateurs
pas d'exception pour la haute assemblée
alors que de nombreux sénateurs la
demande y compris à gauche
les membres de la commission s'attaque
également aux systèmes de parrainage en
vigueur pour les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle même si pour l'heure rien
n'est encore tranché
l'option d'un parrainage citoyen est sur
la table mais il peut y avoir aussi une
option on va dire mixte dans lequel les
partis politiques jouent un rôle plus
grand autre chantier la modification des
modes de scrutin pour les élections
législatives et sénatoriales notamment
pour favoriser l'expression de la
diversité des courants politiques et la
parité
reste à savoir si ces propositions
auront par la suite des répercussions
concrètes dans la vie politique
française
les recommandations il ya quelques
années de la commission balladur sur la
modernisation et le rééquilibrage des
institutions sont restées lettre morte
vous êtes député vous êtes maire vous
choisissez quoi entrée 2 eh bien je vais
vous dire ce qui me choque c'est qu'on
puisse député et avocat d'affaires
ça ça gêne personne ça gêne pas monsieur
jospin ceci avec interdire à des maires
de petites villes comme la mienne d'être
député mais on autorise des députés est
avocat d'affaires ça montre bien que
l'objet c'est de déraciner les élus
c'est ça l'objectif est quand même plus
la génération
si je n'étais pas maire serait plus
député parce que les apparatchiks départ
timoré rayé de la liste
en vérité était ouverte et les grands
partis des grands partis les partis hors
sol des personnalités qui ont toujours
été battu
c'est d'ailleurs en regardant je m'amuse
et je me disais on devrait faire une
commission de tous ceux qui ont échoué
dans la vie politique qu'ont perdu
toutes les élections
j'ose pas les autres qui ont si mal
gouverné que la france est dans cet état
là
je trouve qu'on devrait les mettre tous
ensemble et qu'ils nous disent qu'il
faut faire c'est quand même
extraordinaire
y a qu'en france où vous prenez les
recalés de tous pour nous donner des
conseils de bon allez vous choisir moi
je vous dis que il faut interdire le
cumul de rémunérations ce que je propose
parce que ça n'a pas qu'une question
d'argent pourquoi pas mettre une limite
pour les grandes villes c'est à dire de
100 mille trois cent mille habitants et
pour le reste laissons les députés aient
un statut l'élu et laissons les députés
maires parce que c'est la richesse de
notre vie locale et je crois que cette
mesure est un espèce de totems et que si
vous consultez les français vous verrez
que si on leur dit dans un sondage est
ce que vous êtes content lui dise oui
bien sûr mais quand vous voyez les
électeurs eh bien ils sont contents
d'avoir des élus locaux enracinée qui
siègent au parlement qu'aux l'année
voyons je m'excuse j'insiste encore une
fois je sais pas ce que je pense je dois
rien mais je sais les moyens forcément
attaché à mon mandat de maire on va vous
mettre mara climent racines dans la vie
et je trouve que je me suis peut-être
différent politiquement parce que je
suis maire de banlieue et je suis
profondément attaché à mon rôle
législatif
en revanche je pense qu'il faut
interdire le cumul de rémunérations car
s'il y en a qui font ça pour l'argent il
faut le l'éradiquer donc on verra quand
la loi sera votée mais vous aurez faire
mais il y aura une énième commission
avec le futur premier ministre a échoué
on les mettra tous ensemble à les
remplacer au mercredi à l'assemblée
nationale n'ont pas un gros sous et
sécurité sociale
les députés planchent sur le projet de
loi de finances pour la sécurité sociale
pour 2013 là aussi l'objectif bien sûr
et de réduire les déficits pour cela le
gouvernement a déjà quelques pistes des
explications de 10 à berthelot et après
les 30 milliards d'euros du budget 2013
le gouvernement doit encore trouver 4 à
5 milliards pour financer la sécurité
sociale
là encore les ménages et les entreprises
vont être mis à contribution via de
nouveaux prélèvements par exemple la
hausse du prix du tabac en oeuvre dès
aujourd'hui devrait rapporter 300
millions d'euros l'augmentation des
taxes sur les bières fera rentrer 480
millions d'euros
des mesures qui concerne l'ensemble de
la population autant il est souhaitable
en matière de fiscalité que seules
soient concernés les foyers qui peuvent
contribuer davantage au temps en matière
de prévention et de santé publique
il est souhaitable que tous nos
concitoyens soient concernés imaginez le
scandale qui consisterait à n'envisager
des progrès de santé publique pour les
plus aisés d'entre nous ce serait
incompréhensible
malgré les déclarations de jean marc
ayrault assurant que 90 % des français
ne payerons pas d'impôt supplémentaire
de nouvelles catégories de populations
sont appelées à contribuer un
prélèvement supplémentaire de 0,15 pour
cent sera instaurée sur les revenus des
retraités imposables et les cotisations
d'assurance maladie des artisans
commerçants et professions libérales
seront relevés des mesures controversées
que le gouvernement veut équilibré je
voudrais indiquer que en matière de
santé des mesures d'économies à hauteur
de 2 milliards 1,4 euro demi 2 milliards
400 millions d'euros vont être réalisés
par l'assurance maladie
un gros effort sera demandé à
l'industrie pharmaceutique via des
baisses du prix des médicaments garantie
du ministre du budget jérôme cahuzac
il n'y aura aucune mesures de
déremboursement grâce à ces nouvelles
dispositions le gouvernement table sur
un déficit du régime général de la
sécurité sociale de 11,4 milliards
d'euros en 2013
alors nicolas dupont aignan on imagine
que vous êtes à la place de marisol
touraine bière tabac vous inscrivez vous
écoutez ça fait 20 ans que je vois ça
vingt ans que je vois savez vous aussi
depuis des années toujours les mêmes
cirque
ça n'a aucun sens pourquoi il ya déficit
de la sécurité sociale
parce que principalement nous avons
perdu un million d'emplois industriels
qui ne cotisent plus donc il faudrait
peut-être un jour se poser la question
de cette fuite de l'activité mais bien
évidemment mais est ce que vous
comprenez qu'on est en concurrence avec
des esclaves
est ce que vous comprenez que si on
continue comme ça il y aura plus un
emploi mais moi je refuse cette
mondialisation inhumaine qui est le
moins disant carrière mais je fais ce
que font tous les pays du monde
skf à l'argentine à papa en europe c'est
vrai que les européens sont les bien
aimés pourquoi on changerait pas il faut
sortir de l'europe mais il faut pas
sortir de l'europe on est en europe on
est au coeur de l'europe
il faut changer de politique mais sinon
moi je soyez cohérent il faut que les
gouvernements touraine elle devrait dire
aux français la vérité je ne veux pas
mettre de barrières protectionnistes
donc vous allez avoir le niveau de vie
des chinois dans dix ans c'est à dire un
smic à 300 euros
voilà ce qui va arriver je veux dire
vous ne pouvez pas mais en attendant
déficit on décide de protéger notre
économie comme le fait la corée comme le
fait l'argentine le brésil et même les
états unis comme le fait la chine soit
on passera notre vie a abaissé le niveau
de vie de nos concitoyens pour arriver à
des situations inadmissibles
c'est tout alors certes il ya des
économies à faire mais c'est pas là les
économies fr lieu de mettre des taxes
plus
supprimons la m e parce qu'il n'est pas
normal qu'un étranger irrégulier il est
inadmissible qu'on soit passé de 70
millions d'euros de dépenses à 600
millions pour soigner des gens qui
violent les lois de la république qu'il
y ait des dispensaires j'ai proposé pour
que bien évidemment on est humain des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
puisse se faire vacciner est soigné je
ne suis pas contre mais qu'on arrête ce
flou deuxièmement qu'on réduise les 10
milliards déficit de la sécurité sociale
c'est ce qu'on donne à bruxelles et
qu'on ne retrouve pas le déficit avec
bruxelles ces 10 milliards ben moi je ne
vois pas pourquoi je donnerais 10
milliards d'euros les français pour des
pays qui nous font concurrence et vers
laquelle on délocalise
les règles au fait comment mais
pardonnez moi si déjà vous prenez ces 10
milliards que vous donnez à bruxelles
pour rien faire vous donner des mises à
l'index
mais pourquoi ça n'arriverait plus
attendu excusez moi quand le peuple
français va décider de mettre fin à
cette politique injuste qui consiste à
tondre les français pour donner de
l'argent à l'extérieur du pays il y aura
peut-être enfin on mettra en sommes aux
finances quand on empruntera à 0% la
banque de france pour investir en france
comme le zèle général de gaulle
au lieu de payer des banques privées car
avec l'euro vous savez qu'on fait des
intérêts d'emprunt pour les
investissements publics
on se protégera de la concurrence
déloyale juste un mot verrait donc en
croit son équilibre et quand même une
taxe qui crée la polémique dans ce
budget la sécurité sociale une taxe de 0
15% sur les retraites et les pensions
des retraités pour 2013
est-ce que c'est pas normal que les
nôtres étaient bien qu'ils financent le
dossier la dépendance mais moi je vais
vous dire une chose des retraités à
l'exception de très hauts revenus
ils ont une vie difficile et on a fait
croire on fait croire que les retraités
seraient des nantis il faut vraiment pas
voir le terrain les retraités français
ils ont des petites retraites et on est
en train maintenant de commencer à les
tondre et bien j'espère qu'il se
révolteront de toute façon cette
politique est condamné c'est les
derniers soubresauts d'un système qui va
disparaître simplement moi ce que je
veux c'est proposer aux français une
alternative politique sérieuse parce
qu'on peut changer de politique
avoir des comptes équilibrés et remettre
d'aplomb le pays qui ont l'air d'avoir
avancé on va passer au jeudi avec la
fronde des maires de droite contre le
mariage pour tous
les maires hostiles à ce projet de loi
qui sera présenté dans trois semaines en
conseil des ministres se font entendre
ils sont majoritairement de droite et
refuse de célébrer le mariage en mairie
demandant même à leurs adjoints de les
remplacer pour l'occasion alors pourquoi
cette fronde des maires des explications
de cécile seksu ils disent non un
millier de maires de droite mais aussi
de gauche refuseront d'unir des couples
de même sexe si la loi sur le mariage
homosexuel est adopté jean bizet merde
qui gueule dans la manche fait partie
des frondeurs
le projet est trop éloignée de ses
convictions alors même assis la loi l'y
oblige
il ne célèbrera pas d'union mois
j'exercerai d'une manière ou d'une autre
mon droit de retrait je serai
complètement hors la loi je l'assumerai
d'une façon ou d'une autre mais je
refuserais effectivement un maire n'a
pas le droit de refuser d'unir deux
personnes sauf en cas de polygamie de
mariage blanc ou encore si l'un des deux
époux n'a pas de papiers conforme
d'autres élus pourtant opposés au projet
sont résignés à s'y soumettre
je pense qu'il faut être très prudent
parce que encore une fois le maire n'est
pas simplement leur présentons la
collectivité il est le représentant de
l'état et donc il est chargé d'appliquer
la loi et la loi qu'elle soit bonne ou
qu'elle soit mauvaise malheureusement on
est quand même tenu par un certain
nombre de règles pour éviter de célébrer
ces unions les maires pourront toujours
trouver des alternatives comme demander
à leurs adjoints
mais à force de refus ils risquent des
sanctions je serai de ceux qui
pourraient aussi saisir le préfet pour
que la loi républicaine soient
appliquées en tout point du territoire
la loi est la loi tout le monde doit la
respecter encore plus un premier
magistrat dans sa ville en les maires
soucieux d'appliquer la loi
c'est en tout cas ce qu'espère le
gouvernement qui examinera le projet le
31 octobre prochain
alors vous maire d'yerres essonne
est-ce que vous célébrerez ou pas le
mariage moi je respecterai la loi parce
que je suis républicain jeu
supplémentaire et j'estime que je n'ai
pas à rentrer là dedans sinon c'est sans
fin sans fin
pour autant et pourquoi le gouvernement
pourquoi le gouvernement divise les
français comme ça en vérité je crois que
les socialistes ne mélangeons pas tout
si c'est pas les sondages qui gouvernent
faisons un référendum jeudi à madame
elle me dit les français sont pour après
un référendum vous pourrez dire ils sont
pour aujourd'hui personne ne livre pas
obligatoirement ce que je veux dire
c'est les français aujourd'hui affronte
la misère il faut voir ce qui se passe
dans le pays
l'école de la république abandonner
certains critères l'insécurité
l'emportent et le gouvernement refusant
en fait d'avoir des résultats sur ces
thèmes appliquant la politique au fil de
l'eau se raccrochent les députés
socialistes sénateurs se raccroche à des
emblèmes il croit être moderne
ils vont diviser profondément les
français moi je crois moi j'avais
proposé en son temps c'est ce qu'on
avait dix points lors du débat sur le
pacs au final on se rend compte que le
graët est rentré dans les moeurs de tête
mais moi j'avais proposé en son temps
permettez qu'on puisse penser
différemment
j'avais proposé en son temps l'union où
l'alliance qui était une formule
solennelle parce que quand deux êtres
c'est même de même sexe ils ont le droit
d'affirmer leur amour en mairie mais qui
n'était pas le mariage et ça les
français étaient prêts y avait un
consensus national là dessus mais là ce
qui est très grave dans le projet de loi
qui est pour moi en termes de conscience
impossible
c'est l'adoption ont dit mariage pour
tous mais surtout là on va passer du
droit de l'enfant au droit à l'enfant or
un enfant c'est pas un canari un chat un
chien eux
s'il n'y a pas de droit à l'enfant et ce
qui choque beaucoup l'icône au
compatriote on le voit si vous parlez
des sondages
on le voit partout c'est que l'idée que
deux personnes de même sexe vivent
ensemble cela nuise union c mais
l'adoption entraînée par le mot mariage
est inacceptable et en tout cas je suis
certain qu'ils a pas de consensus dans
le pays là dessus voilà pourquoi vous
avez des mères qui légitimement ont des
réactions de conscience et je comprends
les maires eux je le comprends et je ne
regrette que le gouvernement parce qu'il
échoue dans le domaine économique et
social qu'est la vraie priorité du pays
parce que c'est ça la vraie priorité du
pays
servent de ces mesures pour pour faire
une sorte de marqueurs soi-disant
modernité un peu de paix là dessus ça
serait pas mal cola dupont chacun
respecte et conscience des uns des
autres par d'autres partis qui n'est pas
évidemment de votre bord celui du parti
socialiste qui tiendra son congrès dans
une quinzaine de jours une il y avait
des votes en ce jeudi pour ce qu'on
appelle les motions pour élire le futur
secrétaire le premier secrétaire du
parti
sachez que la motion d'harlem désir a
réuni 68 % des voix la motion de l'ailé
gauche du ps de la motion 3 13,14 et là
surprise
eh bien les venues de la motion de
stéphane hessel vous rappelez évidemment
de ce best-seller indignez-vous qui
obtient 11,9 pour cent des voix là aussi
vous pensez qu'il ya une fronde au parti
socialiste
les nonistes prennent le pouvoir mais il
y a
heureusement dans notre pays des
millions de français qui sont parti
socialiste à l'ump et au front national
au front de gauche à debout la
république qui ont compris que ce petit
système était finie qu'il fallait autre
chose pour le pays et qui résistent
comme il ya eu des résistants dans toute
notre histoire et moi c'est ces
résistants que j'appelle à à nous
rejoindre
hommage aux résistants du parti
socialiste mais écoutez quand j'entends
madame lienemann je me dis heureusement
elle sauve l'honneur de ce parti qui
s'est fait élire sur la croissance sur
des promesses et qui a tous travaillent
déjà au bout de quatre mois
quand vous entendez mais on va
reconstruire la france moi je veux dire
aux français qu'ils nous regardent
on peut faire autrement il n'y a aucune
fatalité mais il va falloir faire un
grand ménage et je n'aimerais pas que ça
se fasse dans la violence j'aimerais que
ça se fasse dans le calme allez pour
finir voici le revenant de la semaine
revoici nicolas sarkozy mais non les
habits de conférencier cette fois cinq
mois après son départ de l'elysée
l ancien président était invité par une
grande banque brésilienne à new york
pour s'exprimer sur l'économie 45
minutes d'intervention durant lesquelles
nicolas sarkozy est apparu détendu je
n'ai jamais eu de vacances aussi longues
de ma vie at il dit et le pire c'est que
je suis heureux de cette situation voilà
ce qu'il a dit l'ancien prétendant
républicain leur nicolas sarkozy la
question tombe se pose est-ce qu'il peut
revenir selon vous m'écoutez c'est une
construction habile maintenant moi je
lui souhaite d'avoir de passer cinq ans
heureux et et puis je crois que les
français veulent tourner la page
profondément pas par rapport à la
personne obligatoirement par rapport au
système et la politique menée et ça vaut
autant pour nicolas sarkozy qu pour
beaucoup d'autres voilà dans le jeu
politique contre 1 qu'on nous impose
toute la journée nicolas sarkozy ne ne
ne démérite pas loin de là c'est une
personnalité forte
mais je pense qu'il a échoué pourquoi
parce qu'il ya eu un fossé un abîme
entre ce qu'il a fait croire aux
français en 2007 et ce qu'il a fait
réellement et que c'est pas la question
du retour qui se pose c'est la question
est ce qu'on est capable de bâtir une
autre politique pour sauver notre pays
pour lui l'an l'empêcher de cette
marginalisation terrible dans la
mondialisation
et pour ça il faut rompre faut rompre
avec cette europe là faut rompre avec la
mondialisation qu'elle a du poids de
retrouver le confort on restait juste
donc c'est pas 10 d'entre vous serez
vous le connaissez un petit peu sincère
bon au fond de vous pour ce qui revient
ou pas je pense qu'il a envie de revenir
mais je pense qu'il n'a pas compris le
sens de sa défaite comme monsieur
ayrault monsieur hollande en menant la
politique qu'il mène depuis trois mois
n'ont pas compris qu'ils menaient le
pays à la ruine et je pense que tous ces
hommes politiques sont prisonniers de ce
qu'ils ont fait depuis vingt ans et la
situation et n'ont pas compris que ce
sont les décisions qu'ils ont prises
depuis vingt ans notamment les fameux
traité d'abandon qui explique pourquoi
la france n'arrive plus à s'en sortir et
je crois qu'il faut reprendre
complètement à la base la politique
française
et là on va le faire merci nicolas
dupont aignan voilà merci en tout cas
vous nous avoir suivi et la
neutralisation très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires bien sûr